Star Trek, I Love Lucy, and The Prisoner are
some of the greatest television shows of all
time.
But they also share another surprising connection:
each of those classic shows has had an episode
banned.
And they aren't alone.
So what could cause a beloved series like
Mister Rogers' Neighborhood to to get yanked
from the airwaves?
Here's a look at why these TV episodes were
banned.
Star Trek: Patterns of Force
The original Star Trek was ambitious in its
attempts at social commentary.
With the episode Patterns of Force, though,
some folks in Germany thought those efforts
went too far.
That's because the episode involved an alien
planet under Nazi-like rule - so Nazi-like
they even used actual Nazi uniforms and symbols.
Luckily Kirk and Spock intervene and set up
a peaceful government instead, but that didn't
keep this episode from being banned in Germany
for decades.
I Love Lucy: The Ricardos Visit Cuba
When Lucy, Ricky, and family traveled to Cuba
in 1956, everybody in America had a big chuckle
at Lucy's hilarious fish-out-of-water hijinks.
But after Cuba became a communist regime under
Fidel Castro, people stopped laughing, and
this episode was banned from reruns for "almost
a decade" despite the fact that it's essentially
just one bad cigar gag after another.
Mr. Rogers' Neighborhood: Conflict
The central focus of Mr. Rogers' Neighborhood
was always on teaching moral lessons to children
through stories and songs.
So how do you explain the Cold War to kids?
Why, with a multi-part epic storyline where
King Friday begins stockpiling bomb-making
materials because he believes Southwood is
gearing up to attack Make-Believe.
The result sounds more like Team America than
Mr. Rogers, with puppets engaging in espionage,
political paranoia, and teaching lessons on
air raids and gas mask use.
"Last time we pretended the people of Southwood
were very much like the people of the neighborhood
of Make-Believe.
They certainly weren't people who were building
bombs for a war the way King Friday thought
they were."
The episodes actually continued to air in
normal rotation until 1996, but haven't been
seen since, other than a few recent attempts
to use them as current political commentary.
Star Trek: The Next Generation: The High Ground
This episode of Star Trek: The Next Generation
featured Picard and the gang getting involved
in a civil war that was a very thinly veiled
commentary on the Irish Troubles.
So thinly veiled, in fact, that the planet's
fictional timeline is actually a timeline
of the Troubles, and Data even directly references
the conflict.
"And it appears that terrorism is an effect
way to promote political change.
Yet there are numerous examples when it was
successful.
The independents of the Mexican state from
Spain, the Irish unification of 2024."
That didn't go over well in the UK or the
Republic of Ireland, especially since the
episode aired just a few months after an IRA
bomb attack at the Royal Marines Music School
in Deal in southern England that killed 11
and wounded 22.
As a result, the episode was banned for almost
two decades before finally airing in 2006.
Ironically, the episode was originally meant
to be about the American Revolution.
In the book Captain's Logs, writer Melinda
Snodgrass explained that she was ordered to
make the change by her bosses.
I wanted it with Picard as Cornwallis and
the Romulans would have been the French, who
were in our revolution, trying to break this
planet away.
Suddenly Picard realized he's one of the oppressors.
Instead, we do 'Breakfast in Belfast,' where
our people decide they're going to go off
to Northern Ireland."
The Prisoner: Living in Harmony
This episode of the surreal series The Prisoner
featured a novel method of trying to psychologically
break down the protagonist Number 6 by placing
him within a virtual reality simulation of
an Old West community and trying to coerce
him into playing the role of sheriff.
The character refuses, though, which may or
may not have led to the episode being banned,
as some felt it was a commentary about conscientious
objectors avoiding the Vietnam War draft.
Officially, the episode was actually banned
because of the show's portrayal of mind-altering
drugs, but since many episodes dealt with
drug use and still aired, sensitivity about
Vietnam seems to be a more likely explanation.
The Big Bang Theory
China is pretty ban-happy when it comes to
imported shows.
They don't need much of a reason, which is
good, because they didn't have much of a reason
when it comes to outright banning The Big
Bang Theory entirely.
The show is actually quite popular in China,
or at least, it was until the State Administration
of Press, Publication, Radio, Film and Television
pulled the plug.
Exactly why is a matter of debate, but some
feel it's because of the rise of diaosi, which
originally was a pejorative term for broke
loser guys without jobs or girlfriends.
Now, though, the term has been embraced by
a generation of young geeks proud of their
so-called loser status who see the characters
in The Big Bang Theory as role models.
And that scares China.
Which is great, because the idea of Sheldon
Cooper as a counter-cultural iconoclast threatening
to destabilize the social order of one of
the biggest nations on Earth is actually more
entertaining than any plot the show could
have ever come up with.
"Bazinga"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!